the sky
appears darker the temperature is
starting to drop
our rivers are freezing crops are
covered in snow
people could go hungry
is it just me or is the sun dimming
are we about to enter a solar minimum
would this help fight global warming
but wait why are nasa and
elon musk so happy
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the sun dims down
the space rumors are true we are at the
beginning of a solar minimum cycle
and nasa expects it to be one of the
weakest in the last 200 years
so what is a solar minimum and
what's going to happen when it arrives
[Music]
to help illuminate let's explain what a
solar cycle is
every 11 years give or take the sun goes
through a cycle where the magnetic poles
flip north becomes south and south
becomes north
during this period the number of
sunspots goes from low
to high with fewer sunspots on the sun's
surface
solar flares and activity significantly
diminish
this is called a solar minimum
it potentially affects the amount of
energy the sun expels
and its radiation levels this could
explain why you
found yourself bundled up in your winter
clothes in the month of june a few years
back
the most extreme example of this
happening on earth was
the little ice age that took place
between the 13th
to mid 19th century cooling temperatures
disrupted the grain harvest and
created an agricultural crisis in europe
during this time temperatures dropped by
2 degrees
nasa predicts even when we reach the
maximum level of this new cycle
it could be 30 to 50 percent weaker than
the previous period
[Music]
that's leading some scientists to
speculate we are entering
into another little ice age for the next
few decades
minus the woolly mammoths
now the flip side of this solar cycle
isn't favorable either
when sunspot occurrences increase it's
called a solar maximum
during this time the sun emits highly
energized particles through space
that are potentially dangerous to all
electronics
and power grids an extreme solar storm
could wipe out power for millions if not
billions of people on earth
in a flash your phone's not working and
netflix is cutting out
the horror intense solar winds
could also cause gps and
telecommunications
satellites to malfunction would you even
know how to get directions without a
disembodied voice telling you which way
to turn
recalculating even worse charged
particles could potentially shut down
essential life support systems and zap
the electrical functions in
any spacecraft that's home to astronauts
plummeting them to earth
but what if the cycle permanently
stopped
at the next solar minimum what if we
dimmed the sun down
could this cool the planet enough to
reverse global warming
well totally understanding the sun is
still a work in progress for the
scientific community
ideas about climate change and whether
solar cycles might contribute either
positively or negatively are plentiful
unfortunately according to nasa's global
climate change team
the news isn't really that glowing they
theorize that the warming caused by
human-induced greenhouse gas emissions
is six times greater than the possible
decades-long cooling
from a prolonged solar minimum even if
the solar minimum were to last
a century global temperatures would
still continue to rise
so maybe we need to start looking for
earth 2.0 after all
but what does this mean in the short
term for our space aspirations
and why is nasa so over the moon happy
well right now nasa is working on the
artemis lunar exploration program
this will put astronauts back on the
moon by the year 2024 so
think of using the solar cycles as
predicting space weather
if you're sending anyone or anything
into space
you want the conditions to be as ideal
as possible
no surprises banana good space weather
equals low levels of solar activity and
radiation
if we can accurately forecast these
conditions
even years ahead we can better predict
when the best time to safely send our
astronauts into space might be
with this insight we could also
safeguard and prepare humanity for the
harmful effects of high solar activity
at the very least we could secure our
vulnerable power grid during this time
continued research into the relationship
we have with our star and
the rest of our solar system would be a
huge help for us on earth
an expected 11-year low would enable us
to formulate
a workable plan for the inevitable
massive solar storm
soon headed towards earth but that's a
story
for another what if